this week a male performance artist
Dylan Mulvaney celebrated his day 365 of
Womanhood actually I need to correct
myself he calls it girlhood not
Womanhood because this grown adult man
is very specifically imitating an
adolescent girl uh it was day 365 of
girlhood then to be precise and I guess
I need to correct myself again because
it was actually day Zero of girlhood he
has experienced precisely zero days of
being a girl or a woman a year from now
he'll still be sitting at zero days
another year after that still zero days
a year after that zero days and when he
dies he will leave this earth a man with
zero days spent being anything other
than a man and when archaeologists dig
up his bones centuries from now they
will know that they are the bones of a
man they won't know the preferred
pronouns of the bones they won't know
anything about the bones except that
they belong to a human male
when everything else is forgotten about
Dylan Mulvaney and everything else will
be forgotten about Dylan Mulvaney the
only fact that will remain is the one
fact he wants us to forget
so with those caveats we turn to
Mulvaney's day 365 celebration at the
Rockefeller Center commemoration really
uh began a day before when Mulvaney
appeared on Drew Barrymore's talk show
and sat there with a pleased expression
on his face when Barrymore literally
knelt at his feet and paid tribute to
the trans deity he went from there to
the red carpet and an even more adoring
crowd his day 365 included celebrity
guests and big musical numbers he uh
pranced around on stage and he basked in
the Applause of an adoring crowd who had
all come out to congratulate him for
pretending to be a girl for the past
year a fawning article in Rolling Stone
tells us that Mulvaney spent a week
rehearsing his day 365 performance it
also tells us that he started developing
the concept
six months ago which means that Mulvaney
had only been quote unquote
transitioning into a quote-unquote girl
for six months when he decided that his
transition needed to be celebrated with
a star-studded Gala in New York
but not everyone who starred in the show
chose to be a part of it in fact as it
turns out I made a cameo appearance
along with the entire rest of the daily
wire crew because every good show needs
a villain and that was our role to play
watch things are going really well like
I just had my first dance as a girl and
oh I can pay my bills and I'm building
up a following and I feel supported and
you know what I'm feeling lucky let's
Google my name
Dylan Mulvaney is intentionally
degrading women every time he does this
woman face Minstrel show routine he is
insulting and demeaning them and doing
it on purpose and he and profiting off
of it and he doesn't care if that is the
most attractive you will ever look then
I don't even want to imagine what you'll
look like when you're at your ugliest
documenting his creepy fetishized
version of what it means to be a girl
well Dylan Mulvaney has had some surgery
to make his face look more like Bruce
Jenner's Dylan Mulvaney has just given
the best proof yet
that transgenderism broadly or at very
least the type of transgenderism that he
suffers from
is a sexual fetish
I just want to stop it there just for a
second and say that this comment from
Michael Knowles is Way Beyond The Pale I
mean how could you accuse this man of
engaging in a sexual fetish is it
because he has recorded videos singing
about his penis bulge
formalize the Bulge we are normalizing
the Bulge women can have bulges and
that's okay we're not gonna stare at
their crotches while they're wearing
their little shopping shorts at the mall
thank you love you bye
okay well I guess that is pretty good
evidence that this is a sexual fetish on
second thought
um all right so let's go back to the the
video then
Dylan is not a woman Dylan is playing a
caricature of a woman that one can say
he is a woman and become one of the most
influential women in America in just six
months of wearing dresses and ironing
his hair the patriarchy always wins gang
oh and there is Dylan Mulvaney as Audrey
Hepburn the difference being that Audrey
Hepburn was an actual woman with a
vagina
I did I showed it what why would you
give them even a second of your big day
well these are the people I have to deal
with on a regular basis so I thought I
should include them in the evening but
that doesn't mean you have to listen to
them well I've always loved a little
constructive criticism maybe there's
nothing constructive about that and it's
not just criticism it's indoctrination
trans and non-binary people have been
around for thousands of years
we have to pause it there again because
of course that's total nonsense
everything in the video is nonsense but
uh this always deserves special mention
billions of human beings lived on this
planet for thousands of years
civilizations Rose and fell without
anyone inventing anything that even
vaguely resembled the modern notion of
trans and non-binary it didn't exist
anywhere at all until a group of weirdo
psychologists and sexologists in the mid
20th century made it all up that's the
actual history correctly told
[Applause]
tricks
I think we've established that I really
like to talk so I don't think they're
going to have the best luck silencing me
truthfully I don't know what their goal
is
but I do know how they make me feel now
that I've built up a thicker skin
it doesn't hurt me
do you want to feel how it feels
do you wanna know know that it doesn't
hurt me
do you want to hear about the deal I'm
making
my response going forward it's not over
explaining myself it's not pleading it's
um it's not
expecting kindness from someone who has
no kindness to give my response is in
the next joyous video that I make
that's my response
[Music]
can we pause there
I'm gonna say something that might make
people feel a little bit uncomfortable
um
it's really hard to maintain a
relationship with God
and I don't think that he made a mistake
with me
um and that maybe one day I will
actually be grateful for being trans
that this isn't some curse but it's just
a different path to the same destination
be running up that road
be running up
you'll be running up that building
[Music]
I'm sorry to cut that off because it's
really quite powerful
um powerful for a few reasons one it
proves that somebody can hit all the
notes and still sound terrible and also
it proves all of the points that we have
been trying to make about this man after
all our entire criticism of Mulvaney is
is that he is not a woman but rather a
performer wearing Womanhood as a costume
his idea of woman is what he learned
from Disney cartoons and how exactly
does he respond to that charge well
by dressing up as a Disney princess
and dancing around on stage and
delivering a tearful monologue while
singing exactly as a Disney princess
would a monologue that by his own
admission he has been rehearsing for a
week as part of a performance he had
planned six months ago so his tears are
then about as authentic as everything
else about him which is to say they are
utterly contrived and staged just more
emotional manipulation meant to shut
down valid criticism I mean imagine a
man you know in black face
singing a self-pitying song about how
his heart breaks whenever someone tells
him that his costume is offensive to
black people that there is no difference
here
Mulaney pretends that he doesn't
understand the criticism
that's because the trans agenda runs
exclusively on falsehoods bad faith and
emotional blackmail and Mulvaney
exemplifies all three he puts on a
cartoonish performance of Womanhood that
is as degrading and absurd as possible
he monetizes the performance he
amplifies it through every platform
available and then when the criticism
rightly comes his wife he acts like he's
just some random person trying to live
his private life and peace
speaking of his critics he says that he
doesn't know what our goals are now
I think he does but for the moment I'll
allow for the possibility that he's as
stupid and oblivious as he wants us to
think he is and so I will explain our
goal is to defend reality and it really
is not any more complicated than that
and here's one reality
no real woman
will ever get a red carpet Extravaganza
at the Rockefeller Center to
congratulate her for simply existing
okay no real woman is going to get that
for actually being a woman for a year
that's the kind of spectacle only
reserved for Dylan Mulvaney a privilege
enjoyed by him and people like him
why is that a problem well for a lot of
reasons but I can illustrate uh one of
the reasons with maybe a brief story
so I think about
when our most recent set of twins were
born uh and uh and I I'll never forget
the moment of course two months ago
standing in the delivery room first baby
born successfully no problems but then
the situation turns dire with the second
the doctor unable to safely deliver
because of a prolapse umbilical cord has
to make a split second decision to
perform an emergency C-section uh it's
uh there's a lot of blood I've never
been in the room for any kind of
operation before I don't know exactly
what I was expecting but I was expecting
all that the blood and um and then there
was my wife you know laying there calm
but shivering at several points on the
verge of passing out the only thing I
could do was hold her hand and tell her
the babies are okay and everything's
gonna be fine and I did tell her that
even though for a period of several
minutes I wasn't sure if it was actually
true but everything was fine in the end
and uh my wife has now taken on the task
of caring for these two infants along
with four other children with Incredible
Grace and joy
and I'm not surprised to see her meet
the challenge that way she's a
remarkable woman I've always known
that's why I married her
and yet
there will never be an event at the
Rockefeller Center to celebrate my
wife's Womanhood okay she's not gonna
have any adoring crowds flocking to bask
in her presence and applaud her and fawn
over her for being a woman
she knows more about being a woman than
Dylan Mulvaney will ever know or could
ever know she's experienced Womanhood at
the deepest level she she Bears its
scars literally she carries its burdens
she knows it's blessing she's a wife a
mother a daughter a sister she's all the
things that Mulvaney and his ilk have
never been and can never understand
and yet he is put on the stage with a
spotlight and the corporate sponsorships
he is celebrated for being what he isn't
it's like giving a medal of honor to
some dude who played Call of Duty in his
basement
now it's not that my wife would want all
of this Fanfare she's not a raging
narcissist like Dylan Mulvaney the point
is simply that by elevating and
celebrating these fake cartoon faux
women
our society has emptied Womanhood of
everything that's truly beautiful and
meaningful and important about it
and if there's any Solace to women they
aren't alone in this boat far from it
the same has happened with manhood uh
the same has happened with with
everything
all that is good and true is hollowed
out
and made artificial and absurd and ugly
you know it's funny that one of Dylan's
cohorts on stage there
says that we as critics
uh want to keep them in The Matrix
now as always the truth is exactly the
other way around
gender ideology is the Matrix
what you just saw there on the screen
that's the Matrix
it's you know I'm sad to say it's not
nearly as cool as the movie version
but that's our version of The Matrix
what you just saw it is a fake alternate
universe it is an artificial projection
meant to obscure reality
and we are urged to play along so as not
to ruin the illusion
but we some of us anyway are tired of
illusions
we are tired of the artificial
we are tired of imitations
we want reality
if we're going to celebrate Womanhood
then we're going to celebrate the real
thing
and that is not you Dylan
and it never will be
and I'll do it for the show today as we
uh move over to the members block if you
want to join us for that you can become
a member and use code walls to check out
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]